[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
guardian's deputy political editor
Jessica Elgort and the times is home
Affairs editor Matt Dayton welcome to
both of you so let's take a look at the
front pages then shall we starting with
the Metro it calls energy companies who
have been using forcible entry power
crazy
the eye has been told by the magistrates
Association that it may be necessary to
change the law to achieve lasting
fairness for customers
and the Daily Star has some less than
flattering things to say about certain
energy bosses well the guardian has word
of renewed calls for a windfall tax on
oil firms after shell reported profits
of more than 32 billion pounds The Daily
Mail carries details of Sky news's
interview with the family of missing
mother of two Nicola bully the headline
people don't just vanish Into Thin Air
charges dropped is the headline for the
Daily Mirror as it reports that
footballer Mason Greenwood won't face
trial
according to the financial times
European Bond markets have responded
well to today's interest rate rises from
Key central banks including the bank of
England apparently confident that they
won't be going much higher
we're reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
that has go straight to Our Guest then
Jessica elgot and Matt dathan Jessica I
know the guardian the eye and now the
times have all done stuff on uh on
prepayment haven't they
um you know there's been outrage in the
industry not least from centrica which
owns British gas about what happened
yeah I mean I think a lot of that
outrage will ring quite Hollow for the
people who have had
um you know the name British the name
British gas hollowed at their door um
and then uh people forcing their way
inside to fit prepayment meters and you
know Graham Stewart the energy Minister
who met
um the chief executive of centric of his
own British gas
um today and also the the head of off
gem which is the Watchdog as basically
he said at the North Jones basically
said now that all suppliers mustn't do
this anymore until there's a major
review
um I mean some of the stuff that's been
revealed particularly by the times about
the use of prepayments meters is
astonishing and really really disturbing
you know forcing
um their way into houses where there are
young children and babies people with
disabilities living there
um on all very much against the
regulations
absolutely going into homes where they
see an older person and saying oh we've
got an easy day I mean it's really
astonishing that anybody can break into
anybody's homes and the whole point of
this map is that prepayment meters were
supposed to be a last resort and not in
vulnerable people's homes so you know
who has allowed this to happen should
there be a real inquiry into this now
absolutely I mean Central who owns
British gas have announced an inquiry
internal inquiry today but it's I think
there's going to be more and more
pressure over the next few days
from MPS to um to call on the government
ready to launch an independent inquiry
into into practices by uh by firms and
off term today of all and all energy
companies to stop this practice
um it is but what strikes me is that
Grant shafts as uh you know last last
month or ordered a Crackdown on this to
to stop um the audience companies to
stop using to stop force between
prepayment meters um on vulnerable
customers and yet this practice still
went on at the same time as that
Crackdown um Times Reporter Paul Morgan
Bentley was was actually undercover
during that announcement and they
continued to carry out these practices
it just shows you that the government
can announce all at once but um actually
sometimes um public interest journalism
is much more powerful well indeed yeah
the the times saying the boss of British
gases parent company centrica city was
really truly sorry Rishi sunak said he
was deeply shocked and concerned the
financial conduct Authority said it was
closely reviewing practices at arvato uh
Financial Solutions the service used by
British gas to collect debt uh meantime
the eye talks about the magistrates
Association suggesting there may be a
case for reviewing the law
um there's concerns about court warrants
to allow these forced entry
um approved they say amid secrecy and
without full scrutiny Jessica
I think that that's a really you know a
big question mark over this
um and something that MPS should
certainly be turning their
um attention to you know but all of
these
um entries were were using a court
warrants that have been obtained from
magistrates and the way it's described
in many of the pieces there's that
magistrates has just kind of given a
list by companies it's done over the
phone
um there's there's very little scrutiny
now that I mean you know I'm I'm I've
I'm not that familiar exactly with how
the process works but there's so if if
if you know there's no checks on
vulnerability at all there's no there's
no requirement for
um the the companies to present evidence
apart from you know the just their own
word for it that these these customers
are not vulnerable and that they're and
that this is a last resort and there
clearly needs to be a different system
in place
um because as soon as people hear uh you
know someone's at their at their front
door with a Court warrant then you know
obviously that that's very very scary
and very Sinister for them and and often
that's the case that you know I mean you
know each time I suspect it is the case
that they're there legally with these
Court warrants but you know you're
wondering you know how they've been
obtained and what's been said in order
to obtain them and Matt the the Metro um
you know picking apart what's been
happening with those uh British gas uh
prepayment uh issues
um and what's happened at Shell
revealing profits uh which had doubled
to 32.2 billion pounds and in fact their
core profits were 84.3 billion dollars
going back to Dollars now
um but after uh tax uh Etc uh obviously
they came down to the figure I quoted of
about 40 billion dollars I mean
extraordinary extraordinary numbers and
many people have said oh there we are
there you need a windfall tax but the
point is of course that you can't tax
profits that are not made in the UK so
this is this becomes a more complicated
argument doesn't it
foreign yeah very much so and um you
just have to look at the comparison with
Europe I think um
I think um Michelle paid tax of about
134 million dollars uh compared to
um about
530 million uh dollars in in Europe so
you just should go to show the
differences there but um I think it's
going to again come back to politics
this question of whether
um whether whether companies making such
huge profits at the same time as
households are struggling with their
bills uh should face a higher wind call
tax and labor already uh seizing upon
this and Miller Band demanding that the
government
um adopt Labor's policy of a 35 uh tax
rather than the 20 the current 25 tax
but it's also just terrible timing I
think given that in April uh just a
couple of months away energy bills are
going to um rocket to an estimated about
3 000 pounds um and when that support
package ends as well from the government
so it's an all round very of bad timing
and it'd be interesting to see if shell
comes out and offers some possibly more
vulnerable customers um a greater help
itself
yes indeed your figures um were right
there shell said it was due to pay 134
million dollars through the UK windfall
tax for 2022 it expects to pay more than
500 billion dollars due to the levy this
year and stressing that it actually paid
1.9 billion dollars a 1.5 billion pounds
in total tax charges to the UK and EU
last year but labor said Mr sunac was
too weak uh the word we always hear at
pmqs to stand up to oil and gas
interests
um Ed miliband
um you know suggesting the uh as the
British people face an energy price like
of 40 in April the government is letting
fossil fuel companies off the hook uh
the lib Dems Ed Davey no company should
be making these kind of outrageous
profits out of Putin's illegal invasion
of Ukraine
um so what what's wrong with the
windfall tax as it has been set up by
Rishi sunak when he was Chancellor then
Jessica
well I think you know ultimately
um that they soon I did introduce a
windfall tax and that was toughened uh
by Jeremy Hunt it where it went up
um uh in the last statement
um uh and you know now it's confetti but
but you know if people would look at the
numbers that you've you've both been
quoting it will seem very much
um like there's you know there's a big
disparity between the amount of tax it's
paying in the amount of bumper profits
that it's posting and even you know CNET
spokesman today you know to journalists
acknowledge that the public would see
these profits as extraordinary
um and and said that that was why they'd
introduce the windfall tax and and you
know they say that that strikes a
balance between encouraging these
companies to invest
um and particularly to invest in in
making sure that you know you have sort
of better energy security but also to to
you know kind of support jobs or Etc but
also you know made acknowledging these
are very extraordinary profits and labor
obviously say that they would go further
and tax these profits more
um even more because they are you know
essentially profiteering from what is a
very difficult situation Glo you know
globally and it's especially affected by
the war in Ukraine
Matt the financial times also
um has it on the front page as well
shell made a record annual profit of
almost 40 billion dollars it says after
a tumultuous year in energy markets set
any questions about their uh where
they're getting the liquid natural gas
from as well shell said it had paid 13
billion dollars in tax worldwide in 2022
but only a hundred million dollars in
the UK
um so this is a conundrum isn't it for
uh Rishi sunak um there seems no
appetite for a tightening of the
windfall rules again or further winful
taxes from this government
no I think Kevin there's a lot of
touring peas would warn against uh
hitting businesses even even harder
because the investment in
um in energy uh resources in the UK so
important for uh for reducing our
Reliance abroad
um especially given they've won Russia
but um and I guess the argument against
hitting the moon harder is that along
with Corporation attacks and the um the
10 supplementary tax there their um
total tax liability is about 75
um although they they can sort of reduce
their tax burden by
um with losses and decommissioning north
of the oil platforms Etc so I guess it's
it's hard argument to make uh against
um increasing windfall taxes on uh
energy firms and especially when I guess
the argument would be
let's hit shell and other companies I
think it'd be very tricky um at the at
the budget but you've also got a factor
in Victorian peas hate any kind of tax
Rises um as including those against
businesses and Tory MPS are clamoring
for for tax cuts so anything that's
going to uh increase if Britain's tax
burden is going to be very unpopular on
the Tory benches
and also on the front page of the
financial times Jessica uh the interest
rate uh decision that we had today and
elsewhere it points out as well that the
Federal Reserve the night before
um so four percent uh possibly
um the peak uh would you reckon
yes I mean so the the four percent is
pretty much for what was expected but is
you know gonna pile a lot of pile
pressure again on on mortgages and
businesses who who've taken out loans
um and and they say that you know it's
particularly needed because of wage
rises in the private sector and and that
that hadn't been forecast but
um
I think there is like there's some room
for optimism some of the stuff that the
bank of England was saying today
suggesting that would be a shallower
recession than anticipating that
inflation is probably peaking now
um and that we won't you know we'll sort
of see
um a recession that doesn't doesn't
gonna go quite as bad and you know go
quite as badly as had previously been
predicted so
um there may well still be this very
similar long-running effect
um but essentially what they're saying
is they're coming faster than expected
and therefore
um the effects you know therefore we
probably we might get through this
period quicker
yeah I mean it was fascinating wasn't it
to hear their assessment of why they
were making the decision and their
prognosis if you like for the UK economy
uh Matt
um for example that any recession we
have technical or whatever will be
shallower possibly and shorter and this
idea of what will cause inflation to
continue well very clearly they said
prices and wages is what will extend
inflation Beyond predicted now you
wonder who that's aimed at during this
strike action that we've seen but uh but
very interesting to hear um the the
governor then
yes I'm sure the treasury will jump on
his remarks about uh the danger of um
offering much higher pay increases for
public sets of workers and I guess the
broader private sector as well uh
because that is one of the biggest
drivers of inflation along with uh Fuel
and uh energy
um but what was really interesting from
Andrew Bailey for me today was um his
analysis that uh the covert pandemic had
had a much longer term effect on the
economy particularly in terms of the
labor market
um and the number of people
um choosing not to participate so mainly
those uh nearing retirement age who
chose to
um retire
um during or just after the pandemic and
and we've heard a lot from Jerry hunt as
well and and the uh working pension
secretary Mel stride about this real
need to try and get
um people in their 50s and 60s who have
retired back into work um and I think
that's going to be a real theme at the
budget next month um but it's just
interesting that Andrew Bailey is really
also
um sending out that public message uh
today yeah I mean he said the
significant and lingering fall in labor
Supply weighs on our economic potential
suggesting this marked Rising inactivity
by 50 to 65 year olds was partly choice
and long-term illness now we know some
of that is mental health illness one
wonders how much of it is covered as
well still or long covered for some
people and certainly Mel stride Jessica
says he has been tasked by Rishi sunak
with trying to tempt people back I'd be
fascinating to see how possible that is
okay yeah and and I know this is
something as well that labor are also
trying to develop policies around it's
something that's really
um kind of baffling people to see this
this extent of inactivity particularly
in the the over 50s people just kind of
checking out the workforce
um a lot of the time it is and and so
much of it seems to be down to mental
health health issues anxiety depression
and and long covert is again kind of
quite difficult to to track in some of
those figures but um but you know it's
it you know how do we sort of persuade
people to to try and get back into work
with flexible hours maybe giving them
some rights for grandparental leave is
one of the things that we've heard
talked about
um you know if they're maybe deciding to
give up work a bit earlier so that they
can
um you know look after you know help
their children shoulder some of the the
cost of living crisis which is affecting
them
um and um you know I think there's also
a question mark about people who you you
have found themselves on long-term
sickness or benefits and ways maybe we
can get them back into work and then
allow them to go you know work doesn't
really work out for them
um and they find it very difficult allow
them to go back on their benefits
without
um being going through a whole
reassessment process which is a thing
that can put people off you know try and
work out in the first place and and
um both Mal Strider and labor have
talked about that being as wonderful
possible solution of a maybe a gentler
approach to to encouraging people back
into the workforce
um you know whether than rather than
kind of using the the stick approach
yeah it's very interesting isn't it um
they might also have given up work to
look after older parents if they can't
get social care there's you know so many
facets of society playing into that now
anyway stay there both of you lots more
still to come including why Afghan
refugees are being told to leave the
capital we'll discuss that next
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Jessica
elgot and Matt dathan from the guardian
and the times welcome back to both of
you
um Matt let's go to the guardian shall
we apologies Jessica and it's your paper
but hundreds of Afghan refugees who had
settled in London after fleeing the
Taliban um the paper tells us have been
told to uproot and move 200 miles away
so why is this
it's quite a shocking story it's uh
because the ongoing practice of housing
around 10 000 Afghan refugees in hotels
and these are people who haven't just
come across the channel in the last few
weeks these are Afghan families who we
evacuated from Kabul in August 2021 so
18 months ago and they're still living
in hotels and local authorities can't
find homes for them the government can't
move them out of hotels and the hotel
contracts obviously expire and so we've
we've had a lot of examples of families
being moved across the country but this
one is extremely worrying because it's
200 miles away Kensington to wetherby in
Yorkshire and it concerns it concerns
150 children so it just shows you that
the disruption that these Afghan
families are facing
um after fleeing the Taliban a year and
a half ago in the UK but people
listening to this at home Jessica would
probably suggest that it doesn't make
any sense to house them in one of the
most expensive parts of the UK you know
Kensington in West London that in fact
actually more of a community feel might
be found for them elsewhere
yeah and I think then it's then then the
question is why can't you settle people
in the first place in the place that
where they can try and start to put down
routes and send their children to school
and find jobs which is what these
refugees have found where they're when
you know where they were initially put
and it's not it's not their fault that
they that that's where they've you know
would initially told they would be
living and and whether he's pretty
familiar to me which is the town where
they've been told they're going to be
sent because it's very close to where I
grew up and you know it's a beautiful
town it's a lovely place to live
um but it's small and it doesn't have a
train station and it's probably
um a lot you know it's a long time maybe
an hour on the bus to Leeds
um and so therefore you know Finding
School places finding jobs moving
somewhere like that is it's not easy
it's not it's not a you know it's not a
place where necessarily there's some of
the skills that some of these refugees
have and some of them have had you know
very skilled jobs before on on
necessarily going to be the place where
they can find them so I think that
that's that's there's no disrespect to
whether it be as a place it's a
wonderful place to live but you know I
think there are reasons why it might not
be the most suitable place to move them
Jessica Matt thank you both very much
indeed thank you both with us through
the 11th but let's take a look at the
weather